disturbing I'm messy cup welcome to unfiltered
that's how one model described right-wing
provocateur Candace Owens late last week after
her comments about a new ad from skims went viral
Owens you might remember was one of Kanye West's
Defenders while everybody else was expressing deep
concern and disgust over his anti-semitism even
her boss daily wire founder Ben Shapiro couldn't
defend owens's defense or maybe you know her
as the woman who complained that women don't
make their husbands sandwiches anymore or who said
she might have grounds to sue the family of George
Floyd for emotional distress or who said racism
is over because well she's never been a Slave
however you've had the displeasure of running
into something Candace Owens has said I'm sure
you regret it but there's something almost
impressive about owens's uncanny ability to
troll the left attempting to own them with
things like anti-Semitism racism sexism and
bigotry in other words all the things the left
already believes that the right embodies walking
right into their generalizations seems like an
odd Flex but her latest attempt at owning the
left seems to have backfired on her podcast she
went after a nearly year-old ad for the Kardashian
shapewear company skims the ad featured a woman
in a wheelchair wearing their new inclusive
adaptive line of underwear and shapewear this
was offensive to Owens who complained I don't
really understand how far we're gonna take this
inclusivity thing we are being ridiculous America
she continued I really don't get it and if I'm
wrong educate me well people did the model who
starred in the ad campaign Haley Rosa actress
Christina Applegate who suffers from Ms and
countless others on social media all schooled
Owens on why this ad was actually a good thing
and not a threat to America see this adaptive
new line features more comfortable closures
and side snaps making it easier for people in
wheelchairs to get into shapewear and underwear
that might not sound ridiculous or terrifying to
you but that's because you're thinking rationally
while it's bad that Owens makes ignorant and
trolling arguments like this it's also very
revealing see Owens likes to talk a lot about
socialism cheats it and it's lurking around every
corner apparently she much prefers capitalism
and she talks about it a lot you can watch her
argue with Russell Brand about the virtues
of capitalism you can watch her explain why
capitalism and free markets are why we need Donald
Trump and you can read her 2020 book in which she
writes glowingly about free markets capitalism and
Entrepreneurship so it's kind of weird that Owens
is picking this fight isn't it isn't this clothing
line an example of an entrepreneur identifying a
gap in the marketplace and filling it isn't
this supply and demand isn't this capitalism
it's funny when your knee-jerk obsession with
owning the libs runs smack into what's supposed
to be your political positions when culture
wars become more important than principles
and policies you get the kind of garbage that
Owens loves to traffic in who cares if it makes
any sense all that matters is that it offends the
right people that's it for me see you next week